merci d'être là légère ciel était très
très proches
sylvie est loin vraiment les venues
d'ailleurs c'est lui d'un gris cendré
tournée qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
lost
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça s'est passé
que la lui a fallu une dose de
médicaments qu'elle alors qu'elle a
failli en mourir donc
comme a dit benjamin castaldi elle a
quand même pas mal de casseroles au cul
elle m'a harcelée sur les réseaux
sociaux a essayé de m'atteindre en
parlant de mon père qui est décédé en
d'ailleurs s'il vit si tu me regardes
j'ai un message pour toi mon père il est
mort en 2013 tu as voulu parler de lui
eh ben il est au paradis il te pisse au
cul voilà oui d'accord
une gueule de sorcières loana elle ne
veut plus voir ta gueule de sorcière qui
est accusé c'est donc car l'amour au
sénat candidate emblématique de
l'émission de télé réalité les
marseillais c'est ça car la mort aux
cons a tous découvert dans les
marseillais south africa ça fait
quelques années maintenant c'est devenu
un personnage culte accusé ça c'est un
fait on peut pas aligner par énormément
de marseillais jusqu'à junien tanti qui
est le pilier d'avoir fait de la
sorcellerie au travers d'une sorcière
réputé à marseille apparemment pour
nuire à des candidats pour faire annuler
des mariages prétextant vouloir être la
star la numéro une
briller c'est grave ça va jusqu'à mettre
les personnes qui travaillent avec elle
dans la sauce notamment deux séances de
sorcellerie sur cédric impliquant des
poupées vaudou dans laquelle une voyante
exécute un rituel pour s'en prendre à
deux autres candidates de télé réalité
regarder ces deux vidéos en premier je
pique ma part que maeva qui était
terriblement w9 et la production et se
fasse virer de moundir ils devront se
séparer de maeva rapidement et
instantanément et que car l'art de
vienne et vienne à tout jamais la
première des candidates de télé les
marchés là effectivement est allé voir
une voyante dès l'âge de 17 ans ça fait
17 ans qu'elle consultait cette personne
je donnais un million trois cent mille
euros à lui a donné pratiquement un
million deux cent mille euros en quatre
à lire donc à lui donne l eau des 300000
euros par an et après ça a dégénéré
effectivement en chantage extorsions de
fonds et cetera mais effectivement carla
était consciente qu'elle allait voir une
voyante effectivement oui il ya eu des
notes audio qui ont été faites car là ne
refait
ne nie pas ses notes audio l'avouer donc
a pas de montage vous avez voulu
analyser les images très vite pourquoi
parce que vous êtes dit je veux savoir
la vérité
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que
vous ici vous avez tous votre vérité
vous avez défendu aux éclairs mais t on
exactement on a été touché par le
témoignage
je veux bien comprendre que c'est
l'empathie parce que moi aussi j'ai été
touché comme vous et moi aussi quand
j'ai vu les premières images
mais ensuite quelque chose et il a perdu
un soldat en 7 6 0 il a perdu l'usagé de
son bras est il à 180 jours d'itt et et
quand on sait que la mesure légale
c'est-à-dire que le seuil légal qui
permet de caractériser un délit ou un
autre est fixé à 8 jours d'itt et et là
on est à 180 jours d'itt et et s'avère
plus de 20 fois
justement le lieu on va dire le seuil
qui est imposé par le code de procédure
pénale le juge a décidé de les mettre en
prison est aujourd'hui sont sous
contrôle judiciaire donc on n'est pas
dans une posture qui est neutre alors
que vous êtes ancien fonctionnaire de
police en moyenne aura des comme vous
mais on se portera je vous dis dessus
moi c'est bien faut vous faut devenir
ministre de l'intérieur si la végétation
les bars on a su être patient j'ai juste
nos patients s'ils pensent que doit donc
voilà je suis policier ma carte est ici
et suspendu six mois pour information
oui oui vous vous êtes d'extrême droite
donc voilà donc si vous voulez on colle
des étiquettes seafrance police un
syndicat d'extrême droite comme celle où
comment que tout ce que ses deux parents
étaient des racistes oui mais oui vous
dites on avait dit ça bah si mais si m
aulas qui disent ah ah oui la vidéo oui
oui oui alors je vais vous dire il ya un
moment où nombre je me dis ça attendez
jamais dit ça toutes vos émissions je
peux vous dire que c'est l'elysée qui
vous font là-bas je lui dis non
je propose de faire s'il vous plaît à
parler reçoit expliquez-vous la marine
qui s'appelle ludovic chancel vous êtes
vous n'avez jamais varié les grilles
alors je fais jamais mariés non mais
vous dites n'importe quoi mais vous
dites n'importe quoi mais vous êtes une
mythomane caractérisée vous n'avez
jamais été marié avec des villes
françaises on est en direct
on aimerait vraiment que ça se passe
bien avec sa série n'y a pour l'heure
exacte rapport à toi où est ton ami fred
commun on n'aime là je n'ai jamais
traité dans la boue comme vous faites
dans les panneaux sur écoute et un
attentat je n'ai jamais été dans la
vraie vie raffinage avait traîné jamais
traité dans la boue comme toi tu fais
avec fred corral il y en a un qui a très
bien parlé
tout est allé si haut sur le plateau yo
ma porte est ouverte et gilles verdez il
a tout compris sur pelé est réel et vous
sortez tous les deux fois métier surtout
cola il était derrière la caméra c'est
dur de passer de bons et il a fait une
entrée excellente
j'ai envie de faire un petit et cheikh
hussein et là j'ai envie de faire des
comptes et du conseil de classe
improvisée anormal meilleur c'est
guillaume genton et le pechoux elle
aussi je suis même pas je suis pas
d'accord avec lui et ça arrive souvent
le trouve toujours pertinent et teillé
est toujours calme et plus mauvaise
élève c'est bernard montiel mais
vraiment sans hésiter boules de la terre
d' importer sais pas quoi dire sur des
mots qui sort de nulle part de son
cerveau les insupportables gym c'est
vraiment le plus nul mais pourquoi parce
que ça s'est mal passé tout à l'heure en
loge mais voulait mais quand même mais
je les adore et vous avez vu un pur pour
les chroniqueurs le meilleur chroniqueur
c'est guy roux jean thomas et le moins
bon c'est bien abouti
non mais la parole et je veux dire si
vous commencez par la victime attendez
vous à ce que je vous réponde ses
principes du contradictoire mathieu
c'est sa douzaine de messages les
commentaires ont dit ces messieurs vous
savez jean raby d'avoir un peu
d'audience ici c'est où vous ferez vous
fait plaisir à ce que la lumière du
plateau vous manteau c'est parce que je
devais beaucoup plus calme en coulisses
que sur le plateau et le suédois si
monsieur vous impliquez vous en avez
passé dans le pas de calais ce week-end
mais je pense qu'il ya plein de choses
qu'on comprend pas honnêtement on est
vraiment des routes
il faut dire la reine et la réalité
honnêtement je pense qu'on pensait
réellement si on suit les modélisations
quand on écoute skis en bois de janvier
que là on serait dans la panade absolue
et que ce serait la fin des haricots
j'espère qu'on sait tous et finalement
le virus nous réservent de nouvelles
surprises mais j'en ai une question est
alors allez-y le mâconnais rumba
demandez peut-être à gilles verdez j'ai
lu avec oui m e division bonjour avait
amené votre petit dossier traditionnels
vous vouliez des études mais voilà je
vais vous répéter la règle et non mais
je vais me viennent du monde entier
vous étudiez mis à part mes allées
vivien aux études il n'y a pas d'autres
recours aux autres allez-y je vous en
filmant l'eau et calédonie mois de
renseignement rider elle m'appartient en
promenade
[Rires]
si vous voulez mais moi dix ans séjourne
à cet effet vous n'êtes pas se remettre
et je ne suis pas dans ce délire raté de
recettes
je regrette je regrette bat énormité
vraiment le cas
tout d'abord je tiens à reconnaître que
je me suis emporté dans votre émission
et que ce n'est pas ma façon d
[Musique]
quand
ou pas c'est fou quelqu'un qui regarde
il voit vous pas regardé une émission
peut faire le plan cette jeune fille et
qui est en train de pleurer parce
qu'elles sont c'est incroyable c'est
trop chou j'ai des petits flashs qui
reviennent michel notaires
la marée basse bonjour monsieur michel
cymes ya pas de vous vous avez préparé
une surprise pour booba oui tout à fait
vous avez un peu de musique c'est pas
biya le kazakh qui me disait toi tu as
au buzzer à chaque fois et au labo si tu
veux plus parler marier dans un institut
base études y joue voilà je m'en fous
balech je m'en fous balech et il sorte
d'accord un moment voici ton âme à une
l'émission à mort
jean messieurs bonsoir merci merci
d'être là koné seydou ba oui oui mais
bien humainement je sais pas mais j'aime
pas seulement six mois au net
moi je n'aime pas ma dis le mais je te
connais pas humainement donc je peux pas
t'aider je peux pas dire si je t'aime ou
pas vous l'aimez pas proposé n'est pas
toléré de racisme non mais moi
ben alors le racing qui dans vos
chansons je le tolère pas vraiment non
quoi comme racine la haine anti
française la n 1 chez les femmes la être
la haine contre les homosexuels
la détestation
allez y les défilés des vérités qui sont
pas bonnes à dire vous parce que vous
avez quelque chose à dire à jean
bessière je peux parler mais je reste
aujourd'hui le rap c'est tout ce que
notre société prétend vénéré d'accord
j'ai quelques jours
[Musique]